vendredi soir 20h Benjamin dans ce rôle
E.Leclerc reçoit un appel de sa centrale
de répartition au signal au superviseur
aux opérations qu'une policière du SPVM
est suspendue par une jambe parce
qu'elle s'est retrouvée prisonnière de
mécanisme automatisé d'une part de
garage
gyrophare et sirène en action chaque
seconde compte dans la circulation dense
du Grand Montréal
de soins avancés parce qu'ils peuvent
donner les médicaments
l'intervention d'urgence se déroule en
hauteur avec l'aide des pompiers qui
utiliseront les pinces de
désincarcération pour libérer la
policière le grave accident est survenu
au moment où elle venait prêter main
forte à des collègues
sur le point d'arrêter ce suspect
considéré armé et dangereux
après 60 minutes d'intervention
minutieuse la jante sera transportée à
l'hôpital pour soigner une grave
fracture ouverte à la cheville
de contrôler sa douleur pendant
l'intervention constant qu'avec elle
était un long moment un trembulancier
par un medique chez urgence santé c'est
desservir 2 millions 500 000 habitants à
Montréal et à Laval les quelques 1100
paramédiques traitent à chaque semaine
près de la moitié de tous les appels
d'urgence au Québec on a aussi beaucoup
problème
de consommation il y en a partout mais
c'est certain que c'est plus concentrer
ici
Benjamin active gyrophare et sirène pour
se diriger vers un autre secteur de
Montréal la soirée est un feu roulant
d'urgence cette fois c'est un homme de
80 ans qui se fait renverser par une
voiture à un coin de rue de son domicile
sans délai il va au secours de l'homme
blessé qui montre des signes
d'hypothermie sur la chaussée rapidement
il doit aussi rassurer l'épouse de
l'homme qui est à couru sur place
de son état c'est pas certain que l'État
qu'on va aller c'est sûr que c'est une
seule personne dans l'ambulance ok
donne-moi toutes les secondes ok si le
réseau de la santé fait face à une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre les paramédics
ambulanciers n'échappent pas à cette
réalité départ volontaire vous vague de
retraite l'Iran se dégarnissent à
vitesse grand V je suis là depuis une
trentaine d'années et urgence santé ne
s'en cache pas les efforts de
recrutement constant peine ta réponse à
la demande cette année nous on avait un
objectif d'embaucher une centaine de
paramédiques on est en mesure de
n'embaucher une quarantaine donc un
manque à gagner d'une soixantaine de
paramédics
il est arrivé par moment cette année
curgence santé se retrouve avec un
nombre d'ambulances atteignant à peine
45% de son nombre habituel qui est
d'environ 50 véhicules pour les gens qui
veulent s'impliquer dans le
préhospitalier qui veulent porter
secours qui veulent venir en aide des
gens de cœur des gens qui ont envie de
faire la différence dans la vie de
quelqu'un donc je les invite à joindre
les rangs de la profession de
paradisique le manque de paramédicte
représente donc un enjeu de santé
publique de taille on souhaite éviter
des conséquences qui pourraient être
dramatiques si on ne règle pas le
problème dans les prochaines années ici
Pascal Robida Radio-Canada Montréal